[Musica]
ciao a tutti mi chiamo già da oggi
compie 51 anni per cui grazie a ted per
avermi invitato proprio oggi grazie
grazie
non avrò molti altri compleanni con
tutti questi applausi per cui l'ho
sfruttato e sono un medico palliativista
sono proprio sono uso il verbo essere
non il verbo fare non perché sia
convinta che fare il medico sia una
scelta vocazionale
ma perché ritengo che essere un medico
palliativista aver accompagnato per 25
anni sono 25 anni che faccio questo
lavoro le persone nel tratto finale
della loro vita abbia rappresentato per
me un percorso dello spirito e in
qualche modo abbia cambiato il mio dna
davvero quei neuroni plastici sono
diventati diversi grazie a questo
percorso che cosa fa un medico
palliativista si occupa di curare quando
non si può più guarire un medico
palliativista sa che si muore
e una cosa che conosce perché vede che
succede tutti i giorni e interviene
quando la medicina che guarisce si è
arresa ha dichiarato il proprio
fallimento è già in queste parole c'è
tutta l'idea di medicina che abbiamo una
medicina che usa dei termini di guerra e
noi che cosa facciamo invece noi
accompagniamo la radice fondamentale del
nostro lavoro è accompagnare
accompagnare un verbo che a me piace
molto perché ha una radice latina e
companies condividere il pane la prima
cosa che si fa tra persone uguali e a
un'altra etimologia un'altra un altro
significato che mi piace molto che è
camminare con l'altro luigina mortari
che ha scritto tra gli altri a una
filosofa che ha scritto tra l'altro un
libro bellissimo che si chiama filosofia
della cura dice che sa avere cura e
cercare un ritmo buono per camminare nel
tempo insieme vuol dire in qualche modo
imparare che la strada la velocità che
ciascuno di noi sa è diversa e diventa
anche un modo per fare il medico non
utilizzando quella che nella lingua
greca si chiama gli a treia che è curare
il corpo malato
ma diventare dei terapeuti nel senso di
nuovo greco del termine laddove il the
wrap on è il serbo quello che mette se
stesso al servizio del servo fidato
quell'umile e allora in qualche modo la
terapia che quella che si applica
veramente è quello quella che quella
forma di cura che le cure palliative
incontrano è uno strumento che in
qualche modo consente di dare di
trasformare il danno biologico il
disease e la parola disease e nella
lingua inglese in un significato
biografico in quella che si chiama
invece il nas che è il significato che
la malattia del corpo a nella mia vita
perché in fondo conoscere la dimensione
della mia malattia è poco importante se
non so che significato porta all'interno
della mia vita e questo dovrebbe essere
il compito di ogni buon medico
trasformare il danno biologico in un
senso biografico perché questo che
chiediamo come persone ci sono degli
studi che dicono che quando un bambino è
colpito da una malattia grave la le
persone che come con dei cerchi
concentrici io immagino veramente il
dolore che si allarga in cerchi
concentrici sono diverse centinaia
perché di fronte a una malattia grave è
una piccola società che si ammala
infatti si dice che le cure palliative
si prendano cura del nucleo paziente
famiglia e come o credo di avere
imparato in questi anni io sono qua a
raccontare quello che ho imparato finora
e più divento vecchia più imparo che non
è tutto che c'è ancora tanto da imparare
e mi piace pensare che accostare le
persone nell'ultimo tratto della loro
vita voglia dire accostarle con
curiosità mi piace che cura e curiosità
inizino allo stesso modo e ho sentito
dire non tanto tempo fa che il giudizio
finisce proprio là dove inizia la
curiosità ecco io non l'ho mai capito
con così tanta chiarezza mi viene da
dire che se io mi accosto a un altro
chiedendomi perché ma proprio quel punto
di domanda anzi che avendo già deciso il
perché dell'altro quello
ecco modo per non entrare in relazione
con lui con un giudizio e spesso io
racconto che cosa faccio e che cosa ho
imparato raccontando le storie dei miei
pazienti anche oggi proverò a farlo
portandovi con me da un paziente che ho
seguito circa un anno fa
e l'idea di raccontare le storie dei
miei pazienti per me nasce da una parte
dalla consapevolezza che non c'è nulla
da aggiungere per me sono maestri io
avevo bisogno di incontrare questo
mestiere ed incontra di incontrare i
miei pazienti per imparare quello che ho
imparato e spero di andare avanti
appunto e poi anche per un'altra ragione
perché mi viene da pensare che se esiste
un aldilà i miei pazienti dove si
trovano ora sentendomi raccontare
guarderanno con tenerezza e con gioia al
fatto che diventino ma essere anche per
altri e se un aldilà non esiste io credo
che ricordare sia portare nuovamente al
cuore allora io porto questi pazienti di
nuovo al cuore e questo per me così è
un'occasione di gioia vi porto con me da
antonio antonio è un nome di fantasia è
un bel signore che abita in una città e
che abita io abito a milano abita nella
città in cui abita anch'io abita in una
casa nel centro della città una casa
molto bella per un signore benestante a
una casa con dei mosaici quando i mobili
d'epoca e io arrivo a casa sua dopo
essere stata a casa di rosa rosa invece
una vecchietta che abita nell'estrema
periferia della città dove abito anch'io
peraltro insieme a sua sorella abitano
nelle case popolari sono povere e ogni
volta rimarcano con uno stupore
incredibile il fatto che noi lavoriamo
sempre in equipe noi io non lavoro mai
da sola che noi ci prendiamo cura di
loro con gentilezza come se la
gentilezza non fosse loro dovuta e
allora per me passare dalla casa di rosa
alla casa di antonio in qualche modo è
prima di tutto esplorare dei mondi e
sapere che per entrare in relazione e
bisogna imparare tante lingue diverse
perché non esiste una lingua buona che
racconti la vita eppure tutti
tutti abbiamo diritto di conoscere
quello che ci serve per vivere
anche per morire nel modo migliore
possibile come dice salvatore natoli che
è un altro filosofo il dolore tutti ci
rende filosofi in qualche modo c'è una
sofferenza che legittima ciascuno di noi
a diventare filosofo e arrivare a casa
di antonio vuol dire entrare appunto nel
suo mondo lui ha un bel signore ha quasi
70 anni mi accoglie sulla soglia e molto
dimagrito e hite rico la sua pelle
gialla perché è malato alla voce ridotta
a un filo
un golf che chiaramente riempiva in un
modo diverso un tempo il ventre teso le
spalle che sembrano un po le brucia
sembra che sia presa delle grucce vuole
ricevermi in sala e io in quel momento
sono medico da salotto sto nel salotto
accetto le sue regole anche se le regole
e questa è un'altra meraviglia di fare
questo lavoro quando si arriva alla fine
della vita si scopre un percorso verso
le essenziali perché quando il tempo è
poco bisogna concentrarsi sulle cose che
contano davvero
io accetto le regole di antonio però la
camera serve solo per essere visitati
dottoresse va bene così ci sediamo sul
salotto il salotto sul sofà e come
sempre io chiedo anche se conosco già la
documentazione sanitario ha già avuto
modo di vederla chiedo ad antonio di
raccontarmi la sua versione dei fatti di
raccontarmi la sua storia e lui inizia a
raccontarmi la sua malattia mi colpisce
molto anche si colpevolizzi che racconti
che non è stato abbastanza attento che
si è ammalato per colpa sua che non è
stato un buon padre che non è stato un
buon marito che se tornasse indietro
farebbe le cose diversamente e io
ascolto in quel momento lì il mio
compito è ascoltare stare in silenzio
chandra candiani che è una poetessa e
maestra buddista in un libro
meraviglioso che si intitola il silenzio
cosa viva racconta come sia proprio il
silenzio che riempie è il vuoto che
riempie noi siamo abituati a riempire di
cose invece il silenzio il vuoto sono lo
spazio che sta tra noi quello che ci
mette in relazione ascolto e poi però
la moglie che è lì con noi interviene a
sua volta rafforzando il fatto che lui
non sia stato effettivamente un grande
marito è un grande padre ma che abbia
fatto tutto quello che era capace di
fare per stare in questa relazione
mi piace molto in quel momento avere la
possibilità di entrare in questa
intimità e di contribuire alla
costruzione di ponti di relazione a
quella manutenzione dei sentimenti che è
così demodé in questo tempo in cui tutto
viene usato e poi buttato via
e invece c'è una manutenzione che aiuta
ad aggiustare le relazioni e che è
preziosissima e mi colpisce molto anche
il fatto che lui si accusi e mi sento in
quel momento lì di dover fare una parte
quasi da agenzia culturale perché non è
vero che si muore per colpa non è vero
che ci si ammala per colpa è vero anche
bisogna avere degli stili di vita
corretto è vero che bisogna fare la
prevenzione primaria e secondaria
e vero che ci sono dei medici che
sbagliano e qualche volta i pazienti
muoiono per colpa dei medici ma
purtroppo si muore perché ci sia male ci
si ammala perché si è vivi perché siamo
programmati per non essere infiniti e
questa è una cosa che spesso si ha un po
dimenticata
a me piace un po sdrammatizzare
raccontando che per quanto i progressi
della medicina siano stati notevoli
la vita è ancora a trasmissione sessuale
e a prognosi infausta nonostante siano
passati tanti e tanti migliaia di anni
in qualche modo
mi spiazza mi spiazza antonio perché è
la prima visita che sto facendo vi
racconto la prima visita è lui a un
certo punto mi dice tutto resta le devo
fare una domanda siamo allenati non
abituati a ricevere domande difficili e
dentro di me si fa strada l'ipotesi che
lui mi chieda la dottoressa quanto mi
rimane ma non c'è davvero più speranza
quando morirò che non sono domande
facile si dice che noi palliativisti
restiamo seduti sulla sedia che scotta
perché anche noi vorremmo prendere e
andarcene perché non è semplice perché
parlare incontrare l'altro che sta
morendo a incontrare anche la propria
morte avendo avere un'anticipazione
e lui invece mi chiedo una cosa diversa
mi dice dottoressa io ho quasi 70 anni
non sono sicuro che ci arriverò e si
ferma a guardarmi ma non è questo che le
voglio chiedere io voglio sapere come si
muore
e questa è una domanda a cui io non so
rispondere e gli rispondo non so che è
una cosa che all'università a me non
hanno insegnato a fare i medici hanno
sempre risposte anche quando non le
hanno anche se adesso la medicina sta
recuperando questo aspetto di incertezza
si dice che più che parlare di diagnosi
bisognerebbe parlare di ipotesi
diagnostiche calare le certezze perché
non ce ne sono così tante e la domanda
di di antonio apre anche a questa
riflessione che per me così importante è
quella che mi costringe in qualche modo
a riconoscermi uomo come lui è proprio
il momento in cui io sento fisicamente
che tolto il camice appoggiato il fondo
il fonendoscopio io sono un uomo un
essere umano esattamente come lui
condivido questa mortalità questa
fragilità questa fisicità questa
bellezza anche di essere viva con la
consapevolezza che il mistero aspetta
anche me sempre chandra candiani dice
che c'è qualcosa di radicale in un
essere umano che nasce e in una vita che
finisce è un'esperienza che supera è
un'esperienza soglia e quante soglia
attraversiamo noi senza esserne
consapevoli e io spiego spiego ad
antonio che io lo accompagnerò ci sarò
ci sarò fino alla fine lo accompagnerò
fino a quella soglia che però a me sarà
dato di superare
una volta sola anche per me come per
tutti gli altri sarà buona la prima non
ci sono altre possibilità e con antonio
si apra loro un'altra riflessione visto
che questo qua resta un mistero
è la richiesta di prendersi cura di
tutto il suo dolore è il dolore alla
fine della vita non è un'esperienza
clinica non è solo un'esperienza fisica
perché il processo del morire è un
processo esistenziale e allora a
prendersi cura significa sì occuparsi
del dolore fisico ma anche del dolore
psicologico e del dolore sociale del
dolore spirituale che si sommano nell
esperienza perché non moriamo come
malati moriamo come esseri umani come
persone
e allora la richiesta di antonio è una
richiesta dissenso laddove senso e qui
rubo le parole di vito mancuso sono
significato sensazione direzione che
quello che anch'io mi chiedo è sempre da
vito mancuso ho avuto così l'occasione
di riflettere sul fatto che se fare
questo percorso quello che è toccato a
me di medico e anche un percorso
spirituale questo non debba essere
necessariamente un percorso di peso
perché non so se voi ci avete mai
pensato io non ci avevo mai pensato ma
spirituale e spiritoso hanno la stessa
radice e chissà se noi fossimo stati se
io penso a me fosse stata educata
sufficientemente a una spiritualità che
abbia la stessa radice di spiritoso
chissà forse avremmo anche un modo di
vivere la religiosità più leggera e
questo mi fa pensare
proprio questa riflessione su sullo
spirito mi fa pensare che per me fare
questo mestiere ha significato una cosa
importantissima che bisogna prendere
tutto molto sul serio senza prendersi
mai troppo sul serio e in questo c'è
anche la consapevolezza che stiamo qua
in prestito che quello che abbiamo è in
prestito e che quando a me prestano una
cosa io ho il compito di restituirla per
lo meno
bene come l'ho ricevuta se non meglio e
allora forse questo qua diventa anche
uno stile con cui attraversare la vita e
ho concluso vi lascio leggendovi questa
frase che è una frase di severino cesari
che era il curatore di stile libero di
einaudi che ha scritto un libro che si è
ammalato ha avuto una vita piena di
malattie ha scritto un libro che si
chiama con molta cura e che dice proprio
nel momento in cui pensi di esserti
preso già abbastanza cura abbastanza e
che potresti accontentarti rimane in
fondo solo quel poco di cui mi occuperò
domani solo quel poco che sarà mai quel
poco
questa è la sicura spia che non ti stai
prendendo cura quanto potresti e non c'è
domani c'è solo la pienezza o il vuoto
di oggi a tua scelta c'è solo questo
giorno questo unico giorno
e io vi lascio con l'augurio che faccio
a voi ea me di saper vivere con pienezza
con gioia e con la giusta dose di
leggerezza ogni singolo giorno
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]